SQUEEZIE Abonnez-vous!! Et bim, j'arrive de ce côté là !
Personne ne s'y attendait.
Les amis, est-ce que vous vous souvenez il y a presque un an quand on avait testé des sites web du futur ?
"ChromeExperiments.com", je le rappelle, un site qui regroupe pleins de sites web qui sont des expériences,
Voilà on teste des trucs, tout ça, c'est assez innovant, c'est assez cool !
Bien sûr, moi j'adore le futur, j'adore la science, hein.
Alors, "Pink Trombone"... C'est quoi ça ?
*Bruits très très bizarres*
Eh ! On a trouvé comment Daft Pink font leur voix !
*Musique*
*Bruits encore plus bizarres*
*rire*
J'ai trouvé ça cool mais j'ai envie de pleurer en même temps, c'est très bizarre !
Oh pu*ain ! Le mec, il a juste reproduit, euh... Comme si je te coupais ta tête en deux.
Voilà, on voyait le système où il y a ta langue et tes cordes vocales etc...
Et tu peux toucher chaque élément, ce qui fait que ça change le son.
Comme quand on se bouche le nez, on parle comme ça, bah là c'est pareil.
Bref, je pense qu'il y a un truc à faire. Je pense qu'un artiste devrait se servir de ce site
Pour faire... euh... les... le sample d'une musique, voilà.
Alors ! Ah... J'avais vu ça "Google Autodraw".
Tu commences à dessiner un truc et il te suggère quelque chose.
Si, par exemple, je veux faire un chat... Hop, c'est ses oreilles.
Bon, pour le moment, il me trouve des arcs-en-ciel, mon gars. *rire*
Hop !
Là c'est un chat. Mais c'est un chat, pu*ain. C'est le visage d'un chat.
Aaah ! Voilà, voilà ! C'est ça que je voulais faire. C'est exactement ça que je voulais...
C'était un ours. Chat-ours, c'est pareil ! Tu changes les quatre lettres, et ça fait le même mot.
Voilà ça ! Voilà, voilà ! Voilà, c'était le visage d'un ours. En fait, j’essayais de vous tromper
pour que ça trompe aussi le site. Excellent, c'est énorme.
Si je fais... Une cafetière.
Voilà c'est ça, une théière je voulais faire.
Bah oui ! Eh bah je vous ai encore trompé.
Je vous ai dit "cafetière", en fait c'était une théière que je dessinais,
mais il a trouvé google. Excellent !
Très bien fait ! Excellent !
Mais euh... Bon voilà...
Moi je préfère mes dessins, je les trouve mieux sans l'aide de ce truc
Donc bon, voilà.
"Ribbons"... Qu'est que ce c'est que "Ribbons" ?
Nananana.... "C'est censé être un fond d'écran. Les couleurs et tout sont générés aléatoirement".
"T'as juste à regarder et à te détendre".
C'est sympa ça ! C'est sympa, mais ça fait une bonne vidéo de m*rde, hein par contre... hein à ça... *souffle*
Là... euh.... Là, pour commenter ça, il faut être chaud, pu*ain.
"Et on observe la bande bleu qui part sur la gauche, bien sûr, pendant que la bande violette"
"Passe, elle, derrière la bande jaune, qui rattrape la bande bleu, qui se multiplie en quatre".
...C'est chiant.
C'est chiant, mais.... Pas mal !
Oh ! Ce site là à l'air dingue !
En gros, tu fais une ligne, et il te trouve une photo de la planète
Où ta ligne, euh.... Est dedans, quoi... Euh... Bon vous allez voir !
Par exemple, je fais une ligne droite, et il me cale la ligne sur une autoroute d'une image.
*rire*
C'est génial !!
Non, mais regarde, c'est abusé ! Je fais une ligne comme ça, et il me trouve...
pile une ligne sur une photo qui... qui correspond.
Non, mais mec... Mais c'est génial !! Non, mais pu*ain, il me troll.
J'ai l'impression de me faire troller en... en permanence.
Eh voilà ! Re du troll et re du trooooll ! Ah là n... Ah non ! Là... là, t'es pas ouf, là...
Ah là t'es pas bien, là. Là, je t'ai un peu "brain", en vrai.
Owah !! C'est quoi ça ?
Ça à l'air très étrange. Très très étrange.
*cris*
On dirait le début d'un mauvais hentai, tu sais...
Non mais en vrai je regarde pas de hentais, c'est faux
Eh voilà, on finit sur une plante. C'était génial.
Expérience très courte, très bien. C'était un bon rapport qualité-temps. J'... j'ai adoré.
Alors ! On arrive sur un site, ok ?
On va parler à Alice. Alice, c'est une femme qui devine l'émotion de ce qu'on va dessiner.
Pensez-vous qu'elle va deviner l'émotion de MES dessins ? *rire*
Elle nous dit... Qu'il a l'air heureux ! *rire*
Alice ! Ça marche bien, Alice ! C'est ça qui fait plaisir, c'est que ce site marche hyper bien ! *ironie*
C'est mieux là, si je fais ça comme ça ?
Ok, là, il est clairement vénère. Elle nous dit qu'il est... content.
Mais non ! Mais Alice !
Mais Alice ! Faut... faut... faut arrêter là !
Il est "angry", ça se voit.
Bon, attends... Je fais une "poker face".
Il a l'air heureux encore... Non mais il est cass... Alice t'es cassée, hein. Ça dégage.
N'importe quoi, Alice, elle nous a bouleversé là, sur ce coup...
"Distort"
Il faut juste... tordre une boule.
Si je comprends bien.
Oh putain, on dirait la matière qu il y a dans les boules euuh..
Dans les lampes pardon, chauffantes là,
Le truc qui monte et qui descend
*Parle doucement* Très bizarre ce que je dis et ce que je fais, avec ma main, mais..
*musique*
"Ouh, you touch my tralala"
uuuoouh *bruit de dégoût*
Ça à l'air dégueulasse ça
Oh mon dieu, qu'est ce qu'on peut faire faire
Vas-y genre...
Attend mais ça, si certains d'entre vous sont en médecine là
C'est d'la balle !
Regarde mon pote
Regarde à quel point on est dégueulasse
On est formidable et dégueulasse à la fois
D'accord, tu choisis ce que tu fait apparaître ou disparaître
Putain c'est maliiin
Là, y a juste plus la peau
Là, on retire le gras
Là, on retire la 1ère couche de muscles, donc on voit les os
Et à la fin il reste quoi ?
WAH putain ça va jusqu'au nerfs, et aux.. putain
C'est génial ça pour les..
Pour découvrir le corps humain, quand tu sais pas trop quoi faire de tes journées
Ou quand t'es en médecine
Oh, encore un truc avec les étoiles, putain j'aime tellement ça..
Eh Thomas Pesquet (astronaute français) revient bientôt d'ailleurs de l'ISS ( station spatiale internationale )
*reportage* "Oh là là Thomas Pesquet est donc sur Terre"
Regardez, si vous vous ne rendez pas compte d'à quel point nous sommes des petites merdes,
je vous le montre quand même :
Ça c'est notre Soleil, d'accord ?
Là y a l'orbite de la Terre, et la Terre, là y a Venus et son orbite,
Mercure, Mars..
Déjà Mars, par rapport à nous,
c'est astronomiquement loin !
On peut y aller, le problème c'est revenir en vrai, ça a mis 6 mois je crois, si on veut y aller
Et quand tu dé-zoomes mon pote
Quand tu dé-zoomes mon pote
Voilà.
Voilà
Voilà tout ce qu'y a en réalité
Non mais parlons-en putain !
C'est incroyable, le jour où on pourra aller aussi loiiin
Bon on pourra, 'fin.. P'tre qu'un jour on pourra !
*bruits incompréhensibles* Laissez moi rêver !
Waaw
Pourquoi ça fait une grosse gueule de con ? *rire*
Pourquoi j'ai une méga gueule de con ?
C'est quoi ce manque de respect là ?
Ah mais le respect dans le futur il est toujours pas là apparemment
On dirait Macron , je ressemble à Macron
*rires*
Je suis ton pire cauchemar Baptiste
Eh oui c'est bien moi, tu ne regarderas plus jamais mes vidéos de la même manière Baptiste
Excellent ce site là, j'ai vraiment adoré
Oh ! On peut jouer du piano à plusieurs !
Alors là mec on va se régaler, on va faire des mélodies exceptionnelles!
Attends mais y a des gens là qui sont en train de jouer?
Oh putain
Attends y a un mec qui joue archi bien !
Pourquoi sur internet dès qu'on partage un truc, qu'on est pleins dessus ça fait toujours un truc de m*rde?
Comme sur les sites où on dessine à plusieurs, tout le monde dessine n'importe quoi
Tout le monde gribouille sur le dessin du voisin !
Pourquoi on est pas foutu de s'entendre bordel ?
Bon, on notera quand même qu'il y a un mec qui fait super bien du piano
et au lieu de jouer dans une gare pour faire kiffer les gens, il va sur ce site !
et il laisse les gens saccager son skill en piano putain c'est terrible !
Salut toi !
Bienvenue dans "Pimp my caisse" bolosse
T'en a marre d'aller dans les concessions pour te faire agresser par des vendeurs ?
Alors va sur ce site et matte des grosses caisses en HD
Met des jantes violettes
Et une peinture jaune, car c'est la mode le jaune
Laisse toi envoûter par cette musique triste
qui te rappelle à chaque secondes que tu n'auras jamais les thunes pour l'acheter
Et heureusement parce qu'elle est franchement dégueulasse
OH, ça ça me plait déjà
Oooh, ça me plait, je sais pas ce qu'on va faire mais ça me plait énormément
Eh je peux la faire cligner des yeux en allant super vite
Hey chuis un ouf
Ok, qu'est ce que je peux modifier d'autres ?
L'expression
Oh mon dieu
*rires*
C'est excellent ça
Lip sync
OH OUI
Et voici la 1ère personne au monde qui arrive à applaudir avec ses lèvres
*bruits de clap*
Ah je pensais que cette blague serait meilleure
Bah voilà, elle est parfaite, elle est splendide
Ah par contre l’œil quand tu regardes tout à gauche il devient pas blanc, si jamais..
Oh, encore un truc avec le visage
J'adore, c'est bizarre hein ?
J'chuis un peu chelou
Oooh, oh, il a l'air tellement vrai
Bon j'avoue pendant une seconde il avait l'air vrai
En vrai, non mais arrêtez
Ah  c'est un vrai mec qui s'est fait scanner ?
Et là je suis en train de le regarder dormir
Oh faut arrêter putain, on va finir en prison un jour
Ok les amis, on va finir en beauté sur un site génial
En gros, c'est un site dans lequel on choisi une vidéo,
tirée d'un film muet, ok ?
Et vous savez les films muets des fois y a, y a du dialogue 'fin
Y a pas de dialogue, mais y a un panneau qui apparaît, avec marqué  ce que le mec a dit
Et là en gros mon micro va détecter ce que je dis,
et il va le marquer dans ce panneau-là
Je vous montre
Bougez pas je vais l'exploser ce p'tit con
Eh le mec dit qu'il va nous exploser, il fait 1m20 ce fils de pute
"Je vais exploser"   *rires*
Ça a fail ! C'est pas grave, ça n'a pas de sens, c'est pas grave, c'est Hollywood
"The End" D'accord
Bon bah voilà, c'était plutôt rapide *rires*
J'ai un peu surcôté le truc, je vais pas vous mentir
Salut, ça va ?
Eh désolé je fais 1m20, mais ta mère
"Désolé je perds mes devoirs et ta mère"
*rires*
Bisous je perds tes devoirs et ta mère ! Je t'aime, à tout à l'heure
Ça n'a pas de fin  !
AAAH, QU'EST CE QUI SE PASSE ?!
Et voilà, incroyable putain !
C'était mon premier court-métrage, n'hésitez pas à le voir au cinéma, à très vite !
Et voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette 3ème vidéo et dernière sur les sites web du futur
En fait ils en ont pas,
N'hésitez pas à aimer si elle vous à plût, pardon
Et en fait ils en ont pas ajouté, euh euh..
'Tain le mec il a une prise de conscience
"Oh mon dieu, j'ai oublié de leur dire d'aimer la vidéo, ma carrière va se terminer si je ne le dis pas !"
Je suis un peu déçu parce qu'en fait y en a pas beaucoup de nouveaux...
Mais bon on était quand même passé à coté de sites qui existaient déjà à l'époque où on avait fait nos 2 autres vidéos,
et qu'on avait pas vu, et c'était super !
Comme ce tout dernier, par exemple
Je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, je vous remercie aussi  d'avoir regardé,
Portez-vous bien, au revooiir ~